la pendiente se define como el cambio en
la dirección vertical y usamos la letra
griega delta que parece un triángulo
para indicar cambio tenemos el cambio
vertical
dividido entre el cambio en la dirección
horizontal
esta es la definición de pendiente y es
una forma razonable para averiguar qué
tan inclinado está algo por ejemplo si
vemos este plano coordenada nuestro
cambio vertical será el cambio en el eje
y dividido entre el cambio horizontal
que será el cambio en la variable x o en
el eje x veamos si esto es una buena
definición para pendiente podemos
dibujar algo que tenga pendiente de 1
vamos a dibujar esta línea con pendiente
de 1
noten que cualquiera que sea mi cambio
horizontal o mx por ejemplo aquí mi
delta x es igual a más 2
tendré el mismo cambio en esta del
taller o el cambio en y también va a ser
igual a más 2 / me cambió en quién es
más 2 / el cambio en x que también es
más 2 y nos da 1 para esta línea su
pendiente será igual a 1
como luce una pendiente de dos pues está
pendiente será más inclinada vamos a
dibujarla vamos a ponerla
comenzando aquí y va a terminar por acá
por cada dos que incremente y solo se
debe incrementar en 1 en la dirección x
en esta línea vemos que por cada cambio
en x igual a 1 mi cambio en y va a ser
igual a 2 mi cambio en james entre el
cambio en x2 entre 1 va a ser igual a 2
por lo que la pendiente la pendiente
aquí va a ser igual a 2 y mientras la
pendiente aumenta la inclinación será
más pronunciada así que esta definición
de pendiente es buena ya que mientras
más rápido aumenta en la dirección
vertical comparado con la horizontal la
inclinación también aumenta y como será
una pendiente negativa veamos un ejemplo
si tenemos un delta iv entre delta x
igual a menos 1 significa que si tenemos
un cambio en x o delta x igual a 1 pues
para poder tener este menos 1 nuestro
delta o el cambio en g debe ser igual a
menos 1 una línea con pendiente menos 1
se verá así ésta la vamos a poner acá y
va a terminar por acá fíjense que
conforme aumenta x en cierta cantidad
por ejemplo si delta x es igual a 1 la
ye disminuye en la misma cantidad del
talle va a ser igual a menos 1 esto es
lo que consideramos una pendiente
descendente
nuestro cambio entre el cambio en x va a
ser igual a menos 1 entre 1 que nos va a
dar igual a menos 1 la pendiente menos 2
va a disminuir aún más rápido una línea
con está pendiente va a verse así ahora
voy a poner esta línea por acá y para
que tenga pendiente menos 2 la tengo que
dibujar o poner así cuando x aumenta 1 y
disminuye 2
cuando x aumentados lleva a disminuir el
doble en este caso menos 4 así que la
pendiente aquí
va a ser igual a menos 2
espero que con eso tengan una mejor
comprensión de lo que representa una
pendiente y como el número de esta
pendiente puede usarse para visualizar
qué tan inclinada está la pendiente si
la pendiente es un número positivo
grande quiere decir que se aumenta
dramáticamente si tenemos una pendiente
negativa pues cuando nuestra x aumenta
la lleva a disminuir y mientras más
negativo sea lleva a disminuir más
rápido